bonjour gérald olivier merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur arte
france pourquoi quitter l allemagne pour
la pologne
quelle stratégie se cache derrière cette
annonce bonjour que d'abord massés de
votre habitation des espaces deux choses
la première c'est que donald trump a un
problème avec l'alba le second c'est que
il a au contraire une très bonne entente
avec la pologne et qu'il entend d'une
certaine façon on récompensait l'élève
modèle et punir le dernier de la classe
alors le problème principal que d'un un
train avec l'allemagne tient au fait que
les allemands sont en retard sur leurs
contributions budgétaires à l'otan
comme vous le savez au sein de l'otan
les 30 pays sont d'accord pour
contribuer à peu près 2% de leurs gdp
leur pib aux dépenses de militaires les
etats unis font 4%
l'allemagne fait 1,1 ou 2% dont ils sont
en retard par rapport à leurs propres
engagements et dans un truck est un
homme d'argent et bien il ne cesse de
souligner ces retards donc c'est le
premier problème qu'il a avec
l'allemagne il a en fait d'autres
problèmes derrière
il a notamment le problème que
l'allemagne a un surplus commercial avec
les états unis dans les échanges et un
déficit de 50 milliards et d'un 1,30
même pas que le commerce extérieur
américain soit déficitaire avec qui que
ce soit donc ils souhaiteraient que les
allemands achètent plus s'il peut mettre
la pression sur eux d'une manière ou
d'une autre il le fera et puis la
troisième problème qui est le fait que
les allemands achètent du gaz naturel à
la russie ils ont un contrat nordstrom
depuis une vingtaine d'années maintenant
et ils achètent pratiquement les deux
tiers de leur gaz naturel à la russie et
d'un attrape ne comprends pas comment un
pays qui a besoin d'être défendus contre
la russie et bien parce par ailleurs des
contrats extrêmement important avec la
russie sur l'énergie le dernier contrat
nordstrom porte sur je crois une dizaine
de milliards de dollars dont ceux des
sommes extrêmement importantes et trump
est vexé de payer pour défendre un pays
contre un ennemi supposer qu'ils aient
la russie alors que ce pays passent des
contrats énergétiques avec la russie
surtout que depuis 2010
depuis que donald trump est arrivée à la
maison blanche les etats-unis sont
devenus un exportateur net de gaz
naturel dont trump souhaiterait que les
allemands achètent du gaz naturel aux
états unis et non plus à la russie et
s'il peut mettre la pression en menaçant
de renonce de retirer un certain nombre
de soldats
eh bien il le fera et puis si on va
ajouter un quatrième point lui et angela
merkel ne se sont jamais très bien
entendu donc ça fait partie de la voûte
que les deux personnages se livrent
depuis plusieurs années alors justement
vous venez de dire donald trump et un
gala merkel qui ne s'entendent pas
forcément très bien justement avec cette
annonce de transfert de soldats quelles
conséquences sur les relations déjà
tendues entre washington et berlin
alors il faut comprendre qu'on est dans
une négociation dans un trompe est
toujours dans une négociation et donc
chacune de ces chacun de ses gestes
chacun de ces tweets chacune de ces
affirmations sont en fait une forme de
négociation
les relations sont déjà tendues je crois
qu'à un moment il faudra les redéfinir
mais on sortira du cadre la relation
bilatérale entre les etats unis l
allemagne et on rentrera dans le cadre
d'une véritable redéfinition de la
mission de l'otan
si vous en souvenez lorsque donald trump
est entré en campagne en 2007 en 2016
pardon il avait à l'époque affirmé que
l'otan était obsolète que l'otan devait
être complètement réformé et dans son
raisonnement l'otan était une
organisation de défense qui avait été
conçue du temps de la guerre froide pour
protéger l'occident contre
l'expansionnisme soviétique
l'union soviétique est décédée a implosé
en 1991 en 2016
quelle était la justification de l'otan
et personne n'a véritablement répondu à
cette question et d'un 1 37 heurter à
l'opposition du complexe
militaro-industriel américain sur le
sujet il ne fallait surtout pas toucher
à l'otan depuis on s'est aperçu qu'il
était devenu le meilleur ami de l'otan
et joe de stoltenberg qui en est
secrétaire général est très content de
la gestion de trump parce que justement
trump lui a permis de remplir ses
coffres
parce qu'un armement des membres de
l'otan se sont mises à payer sous les
menaces de manager maintenant les
relations entre les états unis et
l'allemagne sont pas très bonnes
je pense que les allemands actuellement
joue la montre et c'est de voir si en
novembre
il ya un changement à la maison blanche
s'il y en a un il seront très contents
s'il y en a pas ils s'adapteront à un
deuxième mandat d'un autre homme
justement vous ne parlez du mois de
novembre est ce qu'il faut voir dans
cette annonce un coût politique de la
part de donald trump à cinq mois de
l'élection présidentielle américaine le
3 novembre prochain
alors le seul coup politique pourrait
être lié au fait qu'il fasse rentrer les
soldats aux états unis parce que parmi
les promesses de campagne de donald
trump en 2016
il y avait celle de terminer ces
conflits lointains en irak en
afghanistan et ailleurs de cessé de
déployer des soldats américains sur tous
les théâtres hostiles à travers le monde
et de faire en sorte qu'il rentre au
bercail
là c'est pas tout à fait ce qu'il a
indiqué il a indiqué qu' il allait
déplacer
dix mille soldats environ d'allemagne
sans doute vers la pologne donc c'est
certain seront rapatriés aux états unis
d'autres sans doute la moitié seront
déployés en pologne
on ne sait pas encore où mais
apparemment la pologne est d'accord pour
payer le loyer et l'entretien de ses
bases donc donald trump ferait une
certaine économie le coup pour moi elle
n'est pas si électorale que ça parce que
les américains ne regarde pas de si près
la politique étrangère de leur président
par contre s'il ne peut dire j'ai promis
de faire rentrer les soldats à la maison
et j'ai tenu ma promesse ça suffira pour
lui pour avoir un argument de campagne
de plus merci gerin d'olivier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes un chercheur à l'épaisseur
situe prospective sécurité en europe et
spécialiste des états unis autorise
également du livre sur la route de la
maison blanche aux éditions jean
picollec